Speaker 1: So we just discussed the January six
hearings where some bombshell new information
were revealed or it was revealed. Trump being
supportive of the rioters who wanted to kill
Mike Pence. They wanted to hang Mike Pence. And
Trump supported that. Clear evidence showing
that Trump was being repeatedly told by people
around him that his election claims were false
and much more. So even before these hearings, just
the fact that they were happening in a rage. TRUMP
But then, of course, afterwards he was not too
happy. And before we take a look at where he said
the scary part about all this is if you watched
the hearings, it would it was made so clear,
something we already knew. But it was made really
clear in these hearings that all of this was
motivated by Trump and the people perpetuating
his same lies. People said after the fact,
who were arrested, the ones who had broken into
the Capitol. I did this because President Trump
told me to. Let's take a quick look at that.
Speaker 3: You made me want to come. Was the
fact that. You know, I had supported Trump
all that time. I did believe, you know,
that the election was being stolen and
Trump asked us to come. He personally
asked for us to come to D.C. that day. And
I thought for everything he's done for us,
that this is the only thing he can go after me.
Speaker 1: And then people are reading his
tweets while they're breaking in.
Unidentified: The Capitol might
have the courage to do what's being done to
protect our country and our Constitution. Every
state has to certify a court this set of facts
as fraudulent or inaccurate ones which they were
asked to permanently certify U.S. at the time.
Speaker 1: So all of this was caused by him
telling these lies. And as was revealed, he
was told by people close to him that what
he was saying was not true, that there was no
evidence for the claims he was making, but yet he
kept going out and lying still. And the craziest
part, too, is that we're a year and a half later
still no evidence of the claims he's made, and
yet he's still going off about the election being
stolen. And before the hearings happened, as well
as after the hearings happened, with all these
revelations that came out, his only response
to all of it is to keep telling those lies.
He took the truth social saying, and
this is before the hearings, the select
committee didn't spend one minute studying
the reason that people went to Washington,
D.C. in massive numbers far greater than
the fake news media is willing to report.
So obsessed with that or that the UN selects are
willing to even mention because January six was
not simply a protest, it represent the greatest
movement in the history of our country to make
America great again. It was about an election that
was rigged and stolen random capitalizations for
no reason and a country that was about to go to
hell and look at our country now. And he puts
out another truth saying The UN Select Committee
of Political Thugs, essentially the same group,
brought you the fully debunked in discredited
Russia, Russia, Russia hoax and many other refuse
to study and report and only only goes to make the
exact same point and then we'll skip to after the
hearings happened. So the UN Select Committee
of Political Hacks refused to play any of the
many positive witnesses and statements, refused
to talk of the election fraud and irregularities
that took place on a massive scale and decided
to use a documentary maker from Fake News ABC
to spin only negative footage. Our country is in
such trouble. Well, I could not agree with that
last statement more. Our country is in a lot of
trouble, but for the opposite reasons. And then
he would think so. What he's doing is so
scary because we're a year and a half out
and watching everything that has happened, all the
damage that's been caused by his lies. His only
response to all of that is to keep telling his
lies. So what he's doing is setting up a situation
where the exact same thing could happen again.
This is a massive threat to our democracy. And.
While I totally recognize the Democrats have
so many issues and we should point those out,
criticize them. What they will do and what we know
that Biden would do if he lost the next election
is concede and give up power. And that
is what holds a democracy together.
And so while I know a lot of people on the right
think the statement comes off as hyperbolic.
It's true Donald Trump is the biggest threat right
now to American democracy. Again, I know a lot
of right wingers hear that not only some lefty,
but really think about it. In 2020, he was okay
allowing our democracy, our democratic process,
to fail for his own gain so that he could stay
in power all based off of lies. He was willing
to let all that happen just for his own gain.
How is that not the biggest threat if he's clearly
trying to set up a situation where he can do it
again? He's telling the same lies. And so we can't
withstand another January six. We can't withstand
having a president in power who refuses or does
everything possible to the last second to keep
himself in power even if he lost the election.
We just cannot survive that as a democracy.
And so if you're on the right and you're
reasonable at all, I beg you to think about
with all the issues you probably have
with the left on this. Take a stand for
democracy and the importance of having people
in power who respect our democracy enough to
want to give up power if they lose a fair
and free election. Does it matter? We can
figure out our disagreements later, but as of now,
we should unite conservatives and liberals and I
mean the reasonable conservatives who don't
believe the election lies. To do everything
we can to prevent Trump from getting in power
so that we don't have to go through that again,
where maybe it goes worse next time. Because
I can tell you everything that went wrong for
Trump in 2020 that caused Biden to eventually
get in power. He's going to be ready and not
allow those things to go wrong again. So we do
have to take this seriously. And everyone who is
even somewhat reasonable needs to unite to prevent
him from getting back in power. Super appreciative
to The David Pakman Show for having me fill in
today. Don't forget to check out my channel.
Luke Beesley on YouTube. If you're watching on
YouTube or listening to the podcast, there will
be a link in the description box. Definitely. Go
check me out. We'll be right back with much more.